[موسيقى]
أنا
أجنبي
قادم حتى عام 2016 ، لقد اتخذت قرارًا
بالتصويت لصالح دونالد ترامب
لأنني كنت جمهوريًا وسأصوت
سأصوت ضد دونالد ترامب
عندما ضرب الطمع
وتأثر عملي بشدة ، فقد أغلقنا لمدة
ثلاثة أشهر تقريبًا.
كنت يائسة للقيادة في
قضية covet 19
كأم وكقائدة تعرفها كما هو الحال في
عملي الصغير في عملي الصغير شعرت
أن الناس كانوا يتطلعون إلي
نوعًا ما لضبط النغمة في 25 مايو
كان تاريخ جورج فلويد  مات ليس هناك
شك في أنه الحدث برمته
وفاته
والأيام اللاحقة كانت
مدمرة
لمجتمعنا بأكمله بما في ذلك هنا في
الضواحي
وأنت تعلم أن الكثير منا هادئ جدًا
الآن
إذا نظرت حولك في الشوارع
ليس هناك  الكثير من اللافتات الانتخابية
حولنا أعتقد أن الناس في الضواحي ،
النساء البيض في
الضواحي هنا في مينيسوتا ،
يرغبن في رؤية بلدهن
ومجتمعهن في سلام ،
وأعتقد بشكل خاص الأمهات والنساء
أننا لا نريد أن نرى الفوضى
ستختفي ضواحينا
وستلاحظ مشاكل مثل
أنه لن يكون لديه ضاحية ما لم يأخذ
منعطفًا خاطئًا ، أعلم أن المشاهير
يمضون قدمًا انتظر لحظة نشأت في
الضواحي ، أي من هؤلاء الرجال
لإعطائي سببًا للتصويت لهم
أعطني سببًا  أعطني شيئًا
آخر
[موسيقى]
بعض هذه الحملات الصغيرة لا تقل
أهمية
خاصة بالنسبة للنساء لتشعر بأن لديك صوتًا
أعتقد أنه أحيانًا عندما تنخرط
في
السياسة قد يبدو حقًا وكأنه
يستنزف
السلبية التي تعرفها وقد جعلتني هذه المجموعة
أشعر  حسنًا ،
يمكنني أن أتمنى غدًا أفضل ،
حيث من الممكن أن
يرغب غالبية الناس في
مجتمعات آمنة
وشاملة ومحبّة ، ويمكننا
تحقيق ذلك ، وهكذا
شاركت نوعًا ما وهذا هو السبب في
أنني كنت كذلك
شغوفًا بمحاولة
انتخاب مرشحينا لأنني أعلم أنه
سيحدث فرقًا ،
تقوم منظمتنا بعمل رائع في تمكين
النساء على وجه الخصوص من الشعور بأن لديك
صوتًا ويمكنك أن تكون جزءًا من
المحادثة ، ويمكنك الحصول على مقعد على
الطاولة
i  أعتقد أن الرسالة القائلة
بأن الضواحي تتعرض
للهجوم هي رسالة الخوف
وتحصل على استجابة عاطفية
ولكن بالنسبة لي اخترت إعادة صياغتها
كفكرة حب أشعر أنه
يمكننا أن يكون لدينا مجتمعات
في الضواحي التي تكون شاملة وتلك
البناء  الناس في الأعلى
وحيث يشعر الناس بالترحيب بغض النظر
عن
خلفيتهم ، هل
تفضل مثلي أنا
أنقذ الحي الذي تعيش فيه ، حسنًا ،
أنا أم لثلاثة أطفال وأنا
مؤيد كبير جدًا لدونالد ترامب ،
أشعر أنه متحمس لنا
حتى
يتمكن أطفالنا من الحصول على أمريكا الرائعة ، فإن
الليبراليين يغذون حياة السود
أمرًا مهمًا ،
وهذا ليس صحيحًا فيما
يريده ترامب ، لقد حلمت أن
ابنتي تذهب إلى جامعة
مينيسوتا ،
وبمجرد أن بدأنا نشهد العنف
الدائر
في مينيابوليس  لم يكن
خيارًا متاحًا
ويجب أن يكون لدينا الخيار إذا أردنا
إرسال أطفالنا إلى المدرسة كل يوم أم
لا
[موسيقى]